oh my goodness yo there was a one of the
more iconic moments uh that we always
see when there's Kobe highlights is when
you're on the magic and you pump fake
him with the ball and he does not flinch
um talk talk to me about that game in
that moment and what led up to that and
just kind of because he didn't Flinch at
all and that was kind of you know like
you're you're naturally flinched I don't
care how tough you are you Flinch yeah
everybody flinches in that moment
um first of all I didn't realize how
close it was to his face
um but I just thought what I've always
thought he's a cold [ __ ] like I
like so I met Kobe in 98 so he came to
Lakers in 96 I got to UCLA in 98 and he
was young and so you know well
documented it's kind of an outcast on
that team younger so he used to be on
our campus all the time like eating
chilling talking to people working out
playing picking up so I you know I've
known Kobe on just a what's up level
since I was 18 years old you know and
once I got in the league it was just
always I knew when I was at UCLA used to
sneak back into poly and work out I'm
just like yo this motherfucker's gonna
be him I remember one time when he had a
broken right hand he would do a whole
work I left-handed the whole thing like
he was a left it was incredible I'm just
like what the [ __ ] so you know got a
chance to play with them they were just
always mutual respect you know I mean he
plays hard I play hard
so we get to that situation with the
magic and Lakers they had just played in
the finals the year before yep
um so that following year was like March
getting close to the playoffs and you
know we were both both sides are looking
good so I'm thinking like Hey we're
gonna play these [ __ ] and
finals
um so which is a back and forth game and
and and you know guys that played
against Kobe will tell you like not only
is he a killer but he's like he tries to
mentally
bully you and intimidate you too so he
does all the snake [ __ ] with the elbows
and yeah for sure
El me and my sternum and knocked the
wind out of me that game like I caught a
lot like he tried to he was guarding me
and he tried to block the white shot
from help side and it came out the rim
perfect and I caught a dunk tip and as I
was coming off the room this
[ __ ] hell with me from like my
my growing area to my chest and right
underneath my chin and the rest right
there I'm like you [ __ ] ass
[ __ ] you're not gonna call
nothing huh like so I just got to the
point where
I was gonna fight him and it was dope we
talked about it on my podcast
he wasn't budging I wasn't budget uh but
long story short we ended up beating him
that game
um they go the finals beat boss and we
lose to Boston in the Eastern Finals
Lakers beat Boston in the finals
and then are you on the Lakers the next
year I'm a free agent the next that
summer and
um the the [ __ ] with Orlando fell
through so I was actually
um in toss of Pat Riley to go to the
Heat and he's kind of telling me what's
coming to the Heat and that's when Braun
and Chris Bosh and they're like that's
what he was telling me who are the
crunch time lineup would be and you know
he said it would be you know me uh Mike
Miller d-way Braun and Bosch yeah all of
us are six eight all of us do everything
that could
and then out of the blue I get a call on
my phone for my number I don't have
saved and I really don't answer my phone
anyway for some reason I just answered
it and it was cold
yeah hello yeah what's going on it's
cold I'm like yeah [ __ ] like who is
this yeah I got your number for salsa I
was like oh okay let's see what's
happening
what you gonna do next year I don't know
what you talking about he's like you
know we just start going back and forth
and just like any anybody crazy enough
to [ __ ] with me is crazy enough to play
with me do you want to be a Laker I'm
like hell [ __ ] yeah so uh like
three or four days after that I was a
Laker do you ever think back to like
what would have happened if you went to
the heat oh man I would have won two
champs maybe three maybe three maybe you
would have been the difference against
the Mavericks oh yeah because yeah I was
someone who's in you know put some miles
on dirt
um man yeah never know yeah I mean it's
always but to me it's you know to get a
chance to play like I grew up a Laker
fan yeah of course now help me out here
so you go to the Lakers is this around
the time Dwight and Steve Nash go this
is I'm at the Clippers by then okay okay
that makes sense yeah okay okay come
there yeah and you know that
unfortunately that situation didn't work
out for them